en este momento la voluntad del pueblo
de Guatemala se encuentra en un limbo
tras la orden de la corte de
constitucional de revisar de recontar
ese escrutinio de votos Por lo cual la
misión de observación electoral de
Guatemala pidió que esas cajas donde se
encuentran todos los votos consignados
las papeletas que ahora están
almacenadas en una bodega de el centro
de ciudad de Guatemala pues se resguarde
su integridad para que no vaya a haber
ningún atentado en contra de lo de la
Democracia ahora bien entonces el
tribunal supremo electoral por orden de
la corte constitucional deberá hacer un
reconteo de los más de 5 millones 500
mil votos que se habían emitido el
pasado 25 de junio donde ya se había
determinado que quienes iban a pasar a
segunda vuelta era la candidata Sandra
Torres del partido une y la sorpresa
electoral Bernardo Arévalo de el
movimiento semilla además la corte de
constitucional de constitucionalidad
como se llaman aquí en Guatemala
traslada a la Corte Suprema de Justicia
otra alta corte la creación de un
tribunal de Amparo para garantizar que
este proceso pues tenga un buen
desarrollo pero debemos recordar que esa
Corte Suprema de Justicia debió haber
cambiado sus magistrados desde hace tres
años y medio y son estos mismos
magistrados los que han estado durante
todo el periodo de yamatei sin haber
sido reelegidos y aunque no hay una
fecha Clara la corte pidió que este
nuevo escrutinio se realice lo más
pronto posible y que mientras se haga
los partidos políticos que impugnaron Eh
Pues los resultados tengan la
posibilidad de ver de de presentar todas
sus objeciones para llegar a un Norte a
una Claridad de Quiénes serán los que
pasen a segunda vuelta electoral